hey guys it's max we just got in the
brand new 2021 14-inch redesigned lg
gram
wow i'm gonna say this thing is super
lightweight my first time
holding this and today we're gonna be
comparing it to the m1
macbook pro and we're not only gonna
compare your usual cpu and graphics
performance we're gonna take a look at
the speakers
the webcams and microphones we're gonna
pull out our thermal camera and see how
hot and loud these two get
and test out real world performance and
see which one of these
is the better buy let's start out with
the exteriors and i have to say there
are a few things that i didn't really
expect
first off the lg gram is quite a bit
thicker
than the macbook pro especially at the
back of it you guys can see that right
there
the second thing is i mentioned that the
lg is very lightweight shockingly
lightweight in the hands
but it feels quite cheap it is very
i don't want to say flimsy but kind of
plasticky feeling at least
you look at the lid look how much
movement we have here and everything
just doesn't line up to the premium feel
and fit and finish of the macbook pro
but of course
that is why it is so lightweight i mean
there's a
pretty drastic difference between these
two now i have to give lg props
that they actually added ports for this
redesign how often do you see a
manufacturer do that typically they're
getting rid of ports so
on the left hand side we have a full
size hdmi we have two
thunderbolt 4 ports and we have a
headphone jack which i prefer
on the left hand side and then flipping
around we have
two fast usbs we have a micro sd card
slot and then we have this little lock
so one extra port compared to last year
of course our macbook pro
only has two thunderbolt ports on the
left hand side
and only a headphone jack on the right
hand side so the lg
definitely wins as far as ports both of
them do use usb type-c to charge so
that's a great improvement for
lg i'm not a fan of the brick that's
this two-way setup there's a lot more
cables to deal with compared to having a
little power brick
with little prongs that flip out and
both are about
60 to 65 watts now we do have a big
difference in battery
life especially when you look at the
rated battery life in real world which
i'll talk about in just a bit but for
now let's go ahead and open these up i
love that the macbook opens up
with just one hand as a nice evenly
balanced hinge
let's try the lg and nice okay
i was actually not expecting that since
it's so lightweight
good job lg taking a look at the inside
i have to say that i really dig
this modern clean white look lg made the
trackpad and keyboard bigger
it looks really nice but it feels
plasticky even though it is a magnesium
alloy and it's just very flimsy i'm not
used to that in these modern expensive
notebooks and you guys let me know down
in the comments
what do you prefer a lighter weight
laptop or one that's a lot
stronger and has a lot less flex now
with that let's go ahead and hit the
power button here i'm going to start
booting it up we do have a fingerprint
reader built into this power button
just like on the macbook pro and let's
go ahead and test out the keyboard this
has been improved
and wow okay that feels really nice it's
a little bit springy but it also feels
soft
it definitely feels good gives you a
good amount of feedback and the keys
are a decent size magic keyboard
actually gives you a little bit more
feedback uh but it takes a little bit
less pressure
to press down both are actually very
good let's try
the little track pad all right well
that's actually pretty easy
to press even at the top and it's it is
using a diving board design
so that's good uh but look how much flex
we get there in the chassis i don't know
it just keeps bugging me
now the macbook pro trackpad is bigger
and it is that magnetic trackpad
that just works so well and it feels so
good
definitely is a winner in terms of
trackpad all right we're set up i have a
ton to see about this display but first
i want to cover the speakers
and finish off with the chassis because
the lg doesn't have any speaker grills
like the macbook pro does for up firing
speakers
and it is so lightweight that i'm
curious what kind of speakers they put
into this machine now being on a desk
right now this is the optimal scenario
for down firing speakers because they
bounce up
so let's go ahead and compare these two
put on a pair of headphones if you have
them
and let's take a listen
all right guys let me know your thoughts
down in the comment section below
i have to say that i was surprised with
the lg it is quite a bit louder than i
expected a lot of windows laptops are
quieter but it didn't really sound
good so technically it peaked one
decibel louder than the macbook pro
but it sounds very flat if you're
looking for a good bass
rich maids and nice highs you're not
really gonna get it that's where the
macbook pro really stands out has a nice
rich sound but if you're somebody that's
coming from a cheaper windows laptop
that's quieter and sounds worse i think
most people would be happy it definitely
gets the job done
but it doesn't sound great and now it's
compared to the webcam and the
microphone quality
this is the lg's 720p webcam and it has
dual front-facing microphones here so go
ahead and let me know how this looks and
sounds
and this is the webcam and microphone
quality of the m1
macbook pro so let me know down in the
comment section
which one looks better to you and which
one sounded better and now
let's talk about the displays first off
lg thank you for switching to a 16 by 10
aspect ratio
just like the macbook pro just like so
many windows laptop manufacturers are
doing
it is way better for a laptop of this
size
now they do have a 14 inch display which
is what we want in the max
and we have these nice slim bezels i'd
love to see slimmer bezels on the
macbook pro
i'm not a fan of the matte gray plastic
bezels it reminds me of cheap 300
laptops but at least they are slim now
as far as resolutions
lg just gives you one display it's a
1920x1200 display
so i have 2.3 million pixels compared to
4.1 million pixels on the macbook pro
now i love this kind of
2.5 2.6 k resolution but it looks like
most windows manufacturers is either
getting 1080p based screen
or a 4k one and the 4k kills your
battery life now as far as brightness i
went ahead and adjusted that top camera
so the screens aren't blown out i put
them all up to the max
and i have to say that i'm impressed
with lg because it is almost as bright
as the macbook pro which is at 500 nits
that is great for bright rooms and for
outdoors
but with that said if you're looking at
darker content we do have a pretty
massive difference in reflectivity
and contrast the lg the contrast is much
lower as you guys can probably see from
that camera
and it is much more reflective so i see
my face almost like a mirror and looking
at this
dark content where at the macbook even
though it's a glossy screen
the reflections are minimized and we
have nice rich deep
blacks and lastly color accuracy i read
that the lg supports dci p3 now
unfortunately both of edge and chrome it
is not displaying the wider color gamut
whereas the macbook pro does
so as far as color accuracy if you want
to do photo editing video editing you
care about colors the macro pro is
definitely the better way to go
and now finally let's get into
performance we're going to start out
with the ssds both
are 256 gigabyte models let's go ahead
and hit start
all right so there we go
wow that is a fast read speed on the lg
so as far as right
the macbook pro is leading by about 200
megabytes per second
but for read the lg is about 800
megabytes per second faster we're right
at 3
000 that is incredible now another
difference that we have here
is that the lg gram it actually has an
additional
m.2 slot so you can easily
add in another ssd without having to
remove the one that comes with it so if
you need extra storage
that is quick and easy to do with the
mac of course you're stuck with what you
buy
you have to upgrade it right out of the
gate and now let's compare our cpu
performance we are going to start out
with geekbench 5.
now both of these are 8 gigabyte models
and i have both linked down below
and i'm going to actually do a ram
comparison between
a windows system and a mac with that
unified
memory that gives you better
optimization so if you guys want to see
that video
we're going to do a real world stress
test with applications with web browsing
it's going to be awesome
make sure you guys click that subscribe
button down below and enable those
notifications now let's go ahead and get
started
in our tiger lake intel processor it
goes up to from 2.4 all the way up to
4.2 gigahertz
whereas our m1 mac only hits 3.2
all right we have a result and we have a
massive
difference so as far as single core the
macro pro is about 26
27 faster it's a pretty big difference
but multi-core it is about 60
faster than the lg now the lg we did set
it to the best performance so it's not
supposed to be limited
and you may have noticed that it is
actually plugged in
whereas our macbook pro is unplugged on
battery power now what i'm really
curious about
will lg maintain this performance or
will it go down even more
when we unplug so let's go ahead and
unplug this and we're going to run it
again
all right we are almost done with the
test
and bam we have our results and this is
interesting it looks like as far as
single core score
we actually went up no actually
nevermind we went down by a little bit
it's very close though
a multiscore went up by a little bit and
i do have
my settings set to maximum performance
so that is a very good thing even though
performance isn't as good as the macbook
pro
it does keep its performance without
tanking if you're on battery now what i
am very curious about
is in cinebench when we're pushing these
system to the max how will they perform
and another thing i have to mention is
fan
and heat so far with everything we've
done this thing has been
absolutely silent and most windows
laptops when you open a program
or you do something basic the fans will
kick up for a little bit then they'll
turn back down
so thermals so far look good but let's
go ahead and close this
let's test out the graphics first and
then we'll do our thermal test
and as far as compute performance in
geekbench 5 you guys can see
we have a pretty significant difference
we are looking at
14 700 compared to 21 600 it's about a
50
difference in performance that is
massive and that is with the lg plugged
in now i also did run it
unplugged and the performance went down
by just a little bit
basically insignificant so once again
uh lg i don't know if they're being
conservative with their wattages or what
but the performance is quite a bit low
and now let's see how these compare
in terms of gaming we're using gfx bench
this is scaled pretty well to real world
gaming
and we have our scores here and wow we
have a massive difference
42 compared to 81.33
so basically twice the performance in
terms of
gaming and as you guys may have seen in
our previous videos
the macbook pros when you start to play
games using metal the optimization
is really incredible if you guys didn't
see that go ahead and check it out we'll
link it down below
all right guys and now let's go ahead
and do our maximum performance test with
cinebench it's going to max out all the
cores
and with that i have my thermal camera
right here
so we're going to see how this performs
in terms of temps
in terms of fan noise so let's go ahead
and get a baseline
reading this is our new lg
gram and it looks like 43 degrees is the
hottest point
uh right over there at the back and
let's take a look at our m1
macbook wow 29 degrees you guys see the
color difference between 28 now's the
hottest point
that's a big difference in temperatures
crazy now i do have to commend the lg
for being quiet all these tests the
graphics test we did
the cpu tests we did it has been silent
which has been
really nice for a windows laptop but
this is going to be the big test so
let's go ahead and get started
so this is our 10 minute test where it's
going to keep running for 10 minutes
making sure
the system heats up when we get our full
results and i typically
like to use intel power gadget to see
the cpu frequencies
and the temperatures in the wattage but
it will not open for some reason so
we're just gonna have to go off of the
performance
and our thermal camera all right guys it
has been five minutes and so
far the lg is very quiet it's a little
bit louder than the macbook pro
but i literally have to get that close
to hear it which is wonderful if you
want a quiet machine
let's pull out the thermal camera and
see what we get as far as
temps looks like 48 49
definitely quite hot and still in that
one spot
let's take a look at the m1 36 is our
hardest spot
on the m1 so it's heating up but running
much cooler than the lg
alright guys we are almost done and
let's take another look at thermals we
have 47
on the lg and the mac is at 37 so we
have a 10 degrees
celsius difference that's a massive
difference and
interestingly the macbook pro is
actually slightly
louder now compared to the lg i can't
even hear it which is
really weird for windows laptop but our
macbook pro
does run very cool as far as
temperatures
i wonder if that means that the lg is
gonna be really
weak as far as performance if it's
running that quiet
so our timers are done right now we
gotta finish up with the runs before we
get our score
the mac just finished we have a score of
7755
we're still waiting in the lg the
macbook pro is really
cool right here it's barely warm the lg
wow okay that spot that is burning hot
so this is gonna get interesting we're
almost done and
we have our score let me know down in
the comments pause for a second
what you think the score that it got i
wanna hear your guys's opinions because
i was not expecting this
and i know i say that a lot but i was
really not expecting this
go ahead and let us know the score is 3
357. that is insane i thought it would
at least hit 5 000
but that is so low and that is with the
machine plugged in if we unplug it
i don't think it's going to get any
better performance probably is going to
go down by just a little bit and i did
the math
2.3 times faster for the m1 mac when we
max out all the cores
that is just an incredible difference
now it was quiet
you know i've given props for that but
at this point i'd rather take much
louder fans
even screaming fans to get better
performance than this so
let's go ahead and close cinebench and
now let's get into some real world
performance i have lightroom classic
opened up on both here
let's go ahead and switch between these
42 megapixel images
sit next right there the mac was a
little faster that one is about the same
mac was a little faster mac was faster
so as you guys could see so far the mac
does switch faster even though it's
actually not optimized
for lightroom classic just yet and all
of these raw images have a bunch of
corrections i'm going to grab all 50
and we are going to do an export test
both of these systems are completely
maxed out
it looks like the lg's running at 2.55
about gigahertz it's actually lower than
i expected so it's not actually kicking
up anywhere near that 4.2
and our mac is running at 3.2 gigahertz
the m1 mac is almost done
and it's interesting that i can actually
hear the fan right here from this
distance whereas the lg i can't so they
are
very conservative with their wattages
and their fan speeds
all right our lg is now finally finished
it's silent but it ain't that fast the
macbook pro took 2 minutes and 39
seconds to export all 50 of these edited
raw images
to jpeg the dell took four minutes
and 43 seconds
yes that is no joke no lie
it is quite slow um
it has i5 it has the latest intel
processor
but it's just lg's seems like they're
very conservative and with that
this program is optimized for intel x86
processors
not for m1 max that is close to twice
as long when you need to be maxing out
the cpu and of course
graphics wise there's an even bigger
difference in terms of graphics so
that is a big disappointment with the lg
uh
overall if we take a look at the value
and prices
this thing is a hundred dollars less
than the mac you can toss in your own
ssd
um it has 256 gigs and 8 gigs of ram
it's lightweight has tons of ports so it
looks like it's a fairly good value
it's quiet but then once you get into
performance that's where it starts to
suffer so you guys let me know down
below
what matters for you a lower price more
flexibility a lightweight system a
larger display
or the performance of the macbook pro
and which one would you choose you want
to hear your guys's opinions now
i wanted to compare this to the m1
macbook air
that's even lower and even better value
price wise
and of course um that is fanless so it's
also going to be quiet
quieter than this one but also very
quiet maybe lower performance than the
macbook pro
so if you guys want to see that you guys
can click that circle above
and then we will investigate as far as
performance for our full detailed review
so you guys can subscribe to see that
this has been max and i'll see you in
the next video